The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's
get started.
With the quiz out of the way we
can now move ahead again.
I want to talk a little
bit about the
major renewal theorem.
Partly review, but partly it's
something that we need because
we're going on to talk about
countable-state Markov chains,
and almost all the analysis
there is based on what happens
when you're dealing with
renewal processes.
Especially discrete renewal
processes that are the
renewals when you have
recurrences from one state to
the same state at some
later point.
So, in order to do that, we also
have to talk a little bit
about age and duration at a
given time instead of in terms
of the sample average, because
that's sort of essential also.
And it gives you a nice
interpretation of why these
peculiar things happen about
duration being so much longer
than it seems like it should be,
and things of that sort.
We'll probably spend close to
half the lecture dealing with
that, and the other half dealing
with countable-state
Markov chains.
We really have three major
theorems dealing
with renewal processes.
One of them is a sample path
time average, which we've
called the strong law
for renewals.
It says that if you look at
individual sample paths, it
says that the limit as an
individual sample path, m as
the number of arrivals over that
sample path if you look
at the limit from 0 to infinity
of the number of
arrivals divided by time,
that's 1 over x-bar.
And the set of sample paths
for which that's true has
probability 1.
That's what that statement
is supposed to say.
The next one is the elementary
renewal theorem.
When you look at it carefully,
that doesn't say anything, or
hardly anything.
All it says is that if you look
at the limit as t goes to
infinity, and you also take
the expected value, the
expected value is the number
of renewals over a period t
divided by t.
In other words, the rate of
renewals expected value of
that goes to 1 over x-bar.
Also, this is also leading to
the point of view that the
rate of renewals is 1 over the
expected value of the expected
in a renewal time.
Now, why doesn't that mean
anything just by itself?
Well, if you look at a set of
random variables, which is,
for example, [? zero ?]
most of the time and a very
large value with a very small
probability.
Suppose we look at a set of non
IID random variables where
x sub i is equal to 0, the
probability 1 minus p, and is
equal to some very large value,
say 1 over p, with
probability p.
Let's make it 1 over
p squared.
Then, in that case, this doesn't
tell you anything the
expected value of x sub i if we
look at x sub i as being n
of t over t.
The expected value of x
sub i gets very large.
There's a worse thing that can
happen here though, which is
suppose you have this situation
where n of t
fluctuates within.
And n of t typically looks like
t over x-bar plus the
square root of t.
Now, if you look at this,
I mean this is expected
value of n of t.
And as t wanders around,
expected value of n of t goes
up linearly the way it's
supposed to, but it fluctuates
around that point with
something like
square root of t.
If you divide by t, everything
is fine, but if you look at n
of t over some large period of
time, it's going to move all
over the place.
So knowing that the expected
value of n of t over t is
equal to 1 over x-bar really
doesn't tell you everything
you'd like to know about
this kind of process.
And finally, we have Blackwell's
theorem, which is
getting closer to what
we'd like to know.
What I'm trying to argue here is
that, in a sense, the major
theorems, the things that you
really want to know, there's a
strong law and the strong law
says with probability 1 all
these paths behave
in the same way.
And Blackwell's theorem, if
you take m of t as the
expected value of n of t, that's
the thing which might
wander all over the
place here.
Blackwell says that if the
inter-renewal interval is an
arithmetic random variable,
namely if it only takes on
values that integers time some
span called lambda then the
limit of the expected value of
n of t plus lambda, namely 1
unit beyond where we start,
minus the expected value of t
is lambda over x-bar.
It says you only move up each
unit of time by a constant
here divided by x-bar.
If you look at this long term
behavior, you're still moving
up at a rate of 1 over x-bar.
But since you can only have
jumps at intervals of lambda,
that's what causes that
lambda there.
Most of the time when we try
to look at what's going on
here, and for most of the
examples that we want to look
at, we'll just set lambda
equal to 1.
Especially when we look
at Markov chains.
For Markov chains you only get
changes every step of the
Markov chain, and you might as
well visualize steps of a
Markov chain as being
at unit times
AUDIENCE: I didn't quite
catch the point
of the first example.
What was the point of that?
You said the elementary renewal
theorem [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, the point in this
example is, you might not
even have an expectation, but at
the same time this kind of
situation is a situation where
n of t effectively moves up.
Well, n of t over t effectively
moves up at a nice
regular way, and you have a
strong law there, you have a
weak law there, but you don't
have the situation you want.
Namely, looking at an expected
value does not always tell you
everything you'd like to know.
I'm saying there's more to life
than expected values.
And this one says the other
thing that if you look over
time you're going to have things
wobble around quite a
bit, and Blackwell's theorem
says, yes that wobbling around
can occur over time, but it
doesn't happen very fast.
The second one here
is kind of funny.
This is probably why this is
called somebody's theorem
instead of some lemma that
everybody's known since the
17th century.
Blackwell was still
doing research.
About 10 years ago, I heard him
give a lecture in the math
department here.
He was not ancient at that time,
so this was probably
then sometime around the '50s
or '60s, back when Blackwell
did a lot of work on stochastic
processes was being done.
The reason why this result
is not trivial is because
of this part here.
If you have a renewal process
where some renewals occur, say
with interval 1, and some
renewals occur with interval
pi is a good example of it.
Then as t gets larger and
larger, the set of times at
which renewals can occur becomes
more and more dense.
But along with it becoming more
and more dense, the jumps
you get at each one of those
times gets smaller and
smaller, and pretty soon n of t,
this expected value of n of
t, is looking like something
which, if you don't have your
glasses on, it looks like it's
going up exactly the way it
should be going up, but if you
put your glasses on you see an
enormous amount of fine
structure there.
And the fine structure
never goes away.
We'll talk more about that
in the next slide.
You can really look at this in
a much simpler way, it's just
that people like to look at
the expected number of
renewals at different times.
Since renewals can only occur
at time separated by lambda,
and since you can't have two
renewals at a time, the only
question is, do you get a
renewal at m lambda or don't
you got a renewal at m lambda?
And therefore this limit here,
a limit of m of t plus lambda
minus m of t, is really the
question of whether you've
gotten a renewal at
t plus lambda.
So, you can rewrite this
condition as the limit of the
probability of a renewal
at m lambda as equal
to lambda over x-bar.
What happens with the
scaling here?
I mean, is this scaling right?
Well, the expected time between
renewals is 1 over x-bar.
If I take this renewal process
and I scale it, measuring it
in milliseconds instead
of seconds,
what's going to happen?
1 over x-bar is going to change
by a factor of 1,000.
You really want lambda to change
by a factor of 1,000,
because the probability of a
jump at one of these possible
places for a jump is
still the same.
So you need a lambda over
the x-bar here.
If you model an arithmetic
renewal process as a Markov
chain, starting in renewal state
0, this essentially says
that p sub 0, 0 the probability
of going from 0 to
0 and in steps is
some constant.
I mean, calling pi 0, which is
just what we've always called
it, and pi 0 has to be, in this
case, lambda over x-bar
or 1 over x-bar.
But what it's saying is that
this reaches a constant.
You know, that's the hard
thing to prove.
It's not hard to find
this number.
It's hard to prove that it does
reach a limit, and that's
the same thing that you're
trying to prove here, so this
and this are really saying
the same thing.
That the probability of renewal
at m lambda is lambda
over x-bar, and expected value
of renewals at a given time is
also 1 over x-bar.
So, that's really the best
you could hope for.
If you look at the
non-arithmetic case, I think
one way of understanding it is
to take the results that we
had before, which we stated as
part of Blackwell's theorem,
which is this one.
Divide both sides by delta
and see what happens.
If you divide m of t plus delta
minus m of t by delta,
it looks like you're trying
to go to a limit and get a
derivative.
We know we can't get
a derivative.
So, what's going on then?
It says for any delta that you
want the limit as t goes to
infinity of this ratio has
to be 1 over x-bar.
So, it says that if you take the
limit as delta goes to 0
of this quantity here, you
still get 1 over x-bar.
But this is a good example of
the case where you really
can't interchange these
two limits.
This is not a mathematical
fine point.
I mean, this is something that
really cuts to the grain of
what renewal processes
are all about.
So, you really ought to think
through on your own why this
makes sense when you take the
limit as delta goes to 0 after
you take this limit, whereas if
you try to interchange the
limits then you'd be trying to
say you're taking the limit as
t approaches infinity of a
derivative here, and there
isn't any derivative,
so there isn't any
limit, so nothing works.
Let's look a little bit at age
and duration at a particular
value of t.
Because we looked at age and
duration only in terms of
sample paths, and we went to
the limit and we got very
surprising results.
We found out that the expected
age was the expected value of
the inter-renewal interval
squared divided by the
expected value of the
inter-renewal interval all
divided by 2, which didn't
seem to make any sense.
Because the inter-renewal time
was just this random variable
x, the expected inter-renewal
time is x-bar.
And yet you have this
enormous duration.
And we sort of motivated this
in a number of ways.
We drew some pictures and all of
that, but it didn't really
come together.
When we look at this way
I think it will come
together for you.
So let's assume an arithmetic
renewal process will span 1.
I partly want to look at an
arithmetic process because
it's much easier mathematically,
and partly
because that's the kind of thing
we'll be interested in
going to Markov chains with a
countable number of states.
You're looking at an integer
value of t, z of t which is
the age of time t is how long
it's been since the last
renewal occurred.
So the age at time t is t minus
s of 2, in this case,
and in general it's
t minus s sub n.
So that's what the age is.
The duration x tilde of t, is
going to be the interval from
this last renewal up to the
next renewal after t.
So, I've written
this out here.
x tilde of t is the
renewal time for
the n of t-th renewal.
n of t is this value here.
So what we're doing is we're
looking at how long it takes
to get from here to here.
If I tell you that this interval
starts here, this
distribution here, we'll have
the distribution of x of t.
If all I tell you is we're
looking around t for the
previous interval in the
next interval, then
it's something different.
How do we make sense
out of this?
Well, this is the picture that
will make sense out it for
you, so I hope this
makes sense.
If you look at an integer value
of t, the z of t this
age is going to be some
integer greater
than or equal to 0.
Is it possible for
the age to be 0?
Yes, of course it is, because
t is some integer value.
An arrival could have just come
in at time t, and then
the age is 0.
The time from 1 renewal until
the next has to be at least 1,
because you only get renewals
in at integer times, and you
can have two renewals
at the same time.
So x tilde of t has to
be bigger than 1.
How do we express this
in a different way?
Well, let's let q sub j be the
probability this is an
arrival at time j.
If you want to write that down
with an equation, it's the sum
over all n greater than or equal
to 1 of the probability
that the n-th arrival
occurs at time j.
In other words, q sub j is the
probability that the first
arrival occurs at time j, plus
the probability that the
second arrival occurs at time
j, plus the probability a
third arrival occurs
at time j.
Those are all disjoint events,
you can't have two
of them be the same.
So this q sub j is just the
probability that there is an
arrival at time j.
What's that a function of?
It's a function of
the arrivals that
occur before time j.
And it's independent.
That's how long the next
arrival takes.
If I tell you, yes, there was an
arrival here conditional on
the fact that there was
an arrival here,
which arrival is it?
I'm not talking about t or
anything else, I'm just
saying, suppose we know there's
an arrival here.
What you would look at would be
the previous arrivals, the
previous inter-renewal
intervals, and in terms of
that you would sort out what
that probability is.
Then if there's an arrival here,
what's the probability
that x tilde of t is equal to
this particular value here?
Well, now this is where the
argument gets tricky.
q sub j is a probability
of arrival of time j.
What I maintain is the joint
probability that z of t is
equal to i and this duration
here is equal to k.
In other words, this is equal to
i here, this is equal to k.
The probability of that this q
of t minus i, in other words,
the probability that this is an
arrival at time t minus i,
and the probability that this
inter-renewal interval here
has duration k where the
restriction is that k has to
be bigger than i.
And that's what's fishy
about this.
But it's perfectly correct,
just so long as I stick to
values of i and k, where
k is bigger than i.
i is the age here and
x hat is t, x
tilde of t is the duration.
And I can rewrite that joint
probability as a probability
that we get an arrival here, and
that the probability the
next arrival takes this
time x tilde of t.
Now, what we've done with this
is to replace the idea of
looking at duration with the
idea of looking at an
inter-renewal interval.
In other words, this probability
here, this is not
the pmf of x tilde, this
is the pmf of x itself.
This is the thing we hope we
understand at this point.
This is what you learned about
on the first day of
probability theory, when you
started taking 6041 or
whatever you took.
You started learning about
random variables, and if they
were discrete random variables
they had pmf's, and if you had
a sequence of IID random
variables, this
was the pmf you had.
So this joint probability here
is really these very simple
things that you already
understand.
But it's only equal to this for
i less than or equal to t,
0 less than i, less or equal
to t, and k greater than i.
This restriction here that how
far back you go to the last
arrival can't be any more than
t, it's really sort of a
technical restriction.
I mean, you need it to
be accurate, but
it's not very important.
The important thing is that
k has to be bigger than i
because otherwise you get this
arrival here and it's not
beyond t and therefore it's
not the interval that
surrounds t, it's some
other interval.
So, that tells you what you
need to know about this.
So, the joint probability is
z of t, and x tilde of t is
equal to i and k, is this
conventional probability here.
So what we know, there's a q sub
i as the probability of an
arrival of j that's equal to
the expected value of an
arrival at j and is equal to
the expected number of
arrivals that have occurred.
Excuse me, that i there
should be a j and this
i should be a j.
Oh wait, this is q sub i.
This should be an i and
this should be an i.
If I'm looking at it on my
computer and I don't have my
glasses cleaned I can't tell the
difference between them.
q sub i is the probability
of an arrival at i.
The expectation of the number
of arrivals at i is equal to
the expected number of arrivals
at i minus expected
number of arrivals
at i minus 1.
So Blackwell says, what i is
asymptotically when i gets large.
He says that the limit as
t goes to infinity.
I think this thing's
a little weak.
In fact, it's terribly weak.
So the thing that Blackwell says
is that q sub i goes to a
constant when i gets
very large.
Namely he says that the
probability that you get an
arrival at time i when
i is very large
is just some constant.
It doesn't depend
on i anymore.
It wobbles around for a while,
and then it becomes constant.
This limit here is then 1 over
x-bar, which is what q sub i
is, times the probability
of k.
Now, that's very weird because
what it says is that this
probability does not depend
on the age at all.
It's just a function
of the duration.
As a function of the duration,
it's just p sub x of
k divided by x-bar.
If I go back to what we were
looking at before, what this
says is if I take this interval
here and shift it
around, those pairs of points
will have exactly the same
probability asymptotically.
Now, if you remember what we
talked about this very vague
idea called random incidents,
if you look at a sample path
and then you throw a dart at the
sample path and you say,
what's the duration beyond t,
what's the duration before t,
this is doing the same thing.
But it's doing it in a very
exact and precise way.
So, this is really the
mathematical way to look at
this random instance idea.
And what it's saying, if we go
back to where we were, that's
telling us the joint probability
of age and
duration is just a function of
the inter-renewal interval.
It doesn't depend on
what i is at all.
It doesn't depend on how long
it's been since the last
renewal, it only depends
on the size of the
inter-renewal interval.
So then we say, OK why don't we
try to find the pmf of age?
How do we do that?
Well, we have this joint
distribution of z and x with
these constraints on it. k has
to be bigger than i to make
sure the inter-renewal
interval covers t.
And you look at that formula
there, and you say, OK i
travels from 0 up to k minus
1, and k is going to travel
from i plus 1 all the
way up to infinity.
So, if I try to look at what the
probability of the age is,
it's going to be the sum of k
equals i plus 1 up to infinity
of the joint probability.
Because if I fix what the age
is I'm just looking at all
possible durations from i plus
1 all the way up to infinity.
So, the marginal for z of
t is this complimentary
distribution function
evaluated at
i divided by x-bar.
That's a little hard
to visualize.
But if we look at the duration,
it's a whole lot
easier to visualize and
see what's going on.
If you want to take the marginal
of the duration the
pmf the duration is equal
to k, what is it?
We have to average out over
z of t, which is the age.
The age can be anything from
0 up to k minus 1 if we're
looking at a particular
value of k.
What that is again is this
diagram here, and x-hat of t
will have a particular value of
k here, here, here, here,
all the way up to here.
So what we're doing is adding
up all those values, knowing
exactly what the idea of random
instance was doing, but
doing it in a nice clean way.
Back to the ranch, it says that
the limit is t goes to
infinity of x tilde is going
to be k times pmf of
x divided by x-bar.
You need to divide by x-bar so
that this is a probability
mass function, and we actually
had the x-bar there all along.
But if we sum this up over
k, what do we get?
We get k times the pmf
of x, which is the
expected value of x.
So, that's all very nice.
But what happens if we try to
find the expected value of
this duration function here?
That's really no harder,
the expected
value of the duration.
Here's one of the few places
where we use pmf's to do
everything.
It's a sum from k equals 1 to
infinity of k, which is the k
we had before, k times
px of k over x-bar.
So it's k times kpx of
k divided by x-bar.
That's k squared times the
probability mass function of x
divided by x-bar, which is the
expected value of x squared
divided by the expected
value of x.
Now, that sounds a little weird
also, but I think it's a
whole lot less weird than the
argument using sample paths.
I mean, you can look at this and
you can track down every
little bit of it, and
you can be very sure
of what it's saying.
You can find the expected age
in sort of the same way, and
it's done in the text, and it
comes out to be expected value
of x squared divided by 2 times
the expected value of x,
which is exactly what the
argument was for if you're
looking at the sample
path point.
But you lose a 1/2.
AUDIENCE: When you look
at this [INAUDIBLE]
it was for non-arithmetic
distributions.
And here it's for arithmetic.
So it's always true that the
[INAUDIBLE], even for
arithmetic?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The previous argument we went
through using sample paths was
for arithmetic distribution, as
non-arithmetic was for any
distribution at all.
This argument here, you have
to distinguish between
arithmetic and non-arithmetic,
and you have to distinguish
because they act in very
different ways.
I mean, if you read the text
and you read the section on
non-arithmetic random variables,
you wind up with a
lot of very tedious stuff that's
going on, a lot of
really having to understand what
[INAUDIBLE] integration
is all about.
I mean, if you put in densities
it's all fine, but
if you try to do it for these
weird distributions which are
discrete but non-arithmetic,
you really have a lot of
sweating to do to make sure that
any of this makes sense.
Which is why I'm doing
it this way.
But, when we do it this
way we get this extra
factor of 1/2 here.
And where does the factor
of 1/2 come from?
Well, the factor of 1/2 comes
from the fact that all of this
argument was looking at a t,
which has an integer value.
Because we've made t the
integer, the age could be 0.
If we make t non-integer, then
the age is going to be
something between 0 and 1.
And in fact, if we look at
what's happening, what we're
going to find is that the age
of your integer values into
the 6th, into the
6th plus one.
And you know from the homework
that this might have to be 10
to the 20th, but it doesn't
make any difference.
And now the age here can be 0,
so the average age is going to
be some value here.
And as you look at larger and
larger t's, as you go from
this integer to this integer,
the age is going to increase.
And then at this point
there might be an
arrival at this point.
This is the probability of
an arrival at this point.
Then it goes up again.
It goes up exactly
the same way.
It goes down.
And the value it has at the
integer is its lowest value,
because we're assuming that
when you look at the age
you're looking at an age which
could be 0 if you look at this
particular integer value.
So, where's the problem?
We take the sample average
over time, and what we're
doing is we're averaging
over time here.
So, you wind up with this point,
then you crawl up, then
you go down again, you crawl
up, you go down again.
And this average, which is the
thing we found before for the
sample path average, is exactly
1/2 larger than what
we found here.
So, miraculously these two
numbers jive, which I find
amazing after all this work.
But they do.
And the fact that you have the
1/2 there is sort of a check
on the fact that people have
done the work right, because
nobody would ever imagine that
was there until they actually
went through it and found it.
That, I think, explains why you
get these peculiar results
for duration and for age.
At least, I hope it does.
Let's go on to countable-state
Markov chains.
And the big change that occurs
when you go to countable-state
chains is what you mean
by a recurring class.
Before with finite state Markov
chains, we just blandly
defined a recurrent state of
the state which had the
property that wherever you
could go from that state,
there was always some
way to get back.
And since you had a finite
number of states, if there was
some place you could go, you're
always going to get
back to eventually, because
there was always some path
that had some probability, and
you keep repeating the
possibility of doing that.
So, you didn't have to
worry about decision.
Here you do have to
worry about it.
It's particularly funny if you
look at a Markov chain model
of a Bernoulli process.
So, a Markov chain model of a
Bernoulli process, this is a
countable-state process, you
start out at state 0.
You flip your coin, your loaded
coin, which comes up 1,
so the probability p and tails
with probability q, and if it
comes up heads you
go to state 1.
If it comes up tails, you
go to state minus 1.
So this state here is really
the sum of the x of i's.
In other words, it's the number
of successes minus the
number of failures.
So, we're looking at that sum
and we're looking at what
happens as time gets
larger and larger.
So, you go wandering around
here, moving up with
probability p, moving down the
probability q, and you sort of
get the idea that this
is going to diffuse
after a long time.
How do you do that
mathematically?
And the text writes this
out carefully.
I don't want to do that here,
because I think it's important
for you in doing exercises and
things like that to start to
see these arguments
automatically.
So, the thing that's going to
happen as n gets large is that
the variance of this state is
going to be n times the
variance of a single up or
down random variable.
You calculate that as 1 minus
p minus q squared, and if p
and q are both strictly between
0 and 1, that variance
is always positive.
It can't be negative, you can't
have negative variance.
But the important thing is it
keeps increasing within.
So, it says that if you try to
draw a diagram, if you try to
draw pmf of the probability that
s sub n is equal to 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, and so forth, what
it's going to do is n gets
very large.
Because this pmf is going to
keep scaling outward, and it's
going to scale outwards with
the square root of n.
And we already know that it
starts to look Gaussian.
And in particular what I mean
by looking Gaussian is that
it's going to be a quantized
version of the Gaussian,
because each time you increase
by 1 there's a probability
that s sub n equals that
increased value.
So you're spreading out the
individual values at each
integer, have to spread,
have to come down.
They can't do anything else.
If you're spreading a
distribution out and it's an
integer distribution, you can't
keep these values the
same as they were before or
you would have a total
probability, which would
be growing with the
square root of n.
And the probability that s sub
n is something is equal to 1.
So as you spread out you have
this Gaussian distribution
where the variance is growing
within and where the
probability of each individual
value is going down as 1 over
the square root of the n.
Now, this is the sort of
argument which I hope can
become automatic for you,
because this is the kind of
thing you see in problems and
it's a big mess to analyze it.
You have to go through a lot of
work, you have to be very
careful about how you're
scaling things.
And if you just look at this
saying, what's going to happen
here as n gets large is that
this going to be like a
Gaussian distribution, like
a quantized Gaussian
distribution, and if it
goes out this way,
it's got to go down.
You can't go out without
going down.
So, it says that no matter what
p is and no matter what q
is, so long as neither of them
are 0, this thing is going to
spread out, and the probability
that you're in any
particular state after a long
time is going to 0.
Now, that's not like the
behavior of finite state
Markov chains.
Because in the finite state
Markov chains, you have
recurring classes, you have
steady state probabilities for
those recurring classes.
Here you don't have any steady
state probability distribution
for this situation.
Because in a steady state every
state has probability 0,
and those probabilities don't
add to 1, so you just can't
deal with this in any
sensible way.
So, here we have a
countable-state Markov chain,
which doesn't behave at all like
the finite state Markov
chains we've looked at before.
What's the period of this
chain, by the way?
I said, here it's equal to
2, why is it equal to 2?
Well, you start out at an even
number, s sub n is equal to 0,
after one transition s sub n is
odd, after two transitions
it's even again, so it keeps
oscillating between even and
odd, which means there's
a period of two.
So, we have a situation where
all states communicate.
The definition of communicate is
the same as it was before.
There's a path they get from
here to there, and there's a
path to get back again.
And classes are the same as
they were before, a set of
states which all communicate
with each other, are all in
the same class, and if i and j
communicate, then if j and k
communicate, then there's a path
to get from i to j and a
path to get from j to k, to the
path to get from i to k,
to the path to get back again.
So if i and j communicate and
j and k communicate, then i
and k communicate also,
which is why you get
classes out of this.
So, we have classes.
What we don't have is anything
relating to steady state
probabilities, necessarily.
So what we do?
Well, another example, that's
called a birth-death chain, we
will see this much more often
than the ugly thing I had in
the last slide.
The ugly thing I had in the
last slide is really much
simpler, but it's harder
to analyze.
It's gruesome.
Well, as a matter of fact, we
probably ought to talk about
this a little further.
Because this does something.
If you pick p equal to 1/2, this
thing is going to expand
the center of it for any n is
going to stay at 0, so the
probability of each
state is going to
get smaller and smaller.
What's the probability when you
start at 0 that you ever
get back to 0 again?
Now, that's not an easy
question, it's a question that
takes a good deal of analysis
and a good deal of head
scratching.
But the answer is 1.
There's a 0 steady state
probability of being in state
0, but you wander away and
you eventually get back.
There's always a path to come
back, and no matter how far
away you get it's just as easy
to get back as it was to get
out there, so it's certainly
plausible that you ought to
get back with probability 1.
And we will probably prove
that at some point.
I'm not going to prove it today
because it would just be
too much to prove for today.
And, also, you will
need to have done
a few of the exercises.
The homework set for this week
is kind of easy, because
you're probably all exhausted
after studying for the quiz.
I hope the quiz was easy, but
even if it was easy you still
had to study for it, and
that's the thing
that takes the time.
So this week we won't do too
much, but you will get some
experience working with
a set of ideas.
We want to go to this next
thing, which is called a
birth-death chain.
There are only non-negative
states here, 0, 1, 2.
It looks exactly the same as the
previous chain, except you
can't go negative.
Whenever you go down to 0 you
bounce around and you then can
go up again and come
back again as
sort of like an accordion.
If p is less than 1/2, you can
sort of imagine what's going
to happen here.
Every time you go up there's a
force pulling you back that's
bigger than the force going up,
so you can imagine that
you're going to stay clustered
pretty close to 0.
If p is greater than 1/2, you're
going to go off into
the wild blue yonder, and you're
never going to come
back eventually, but if p is
equal to 1/2 then it's kind of
hard to see what's going
to happen again.
It's the same as the
situation before.
You will come back with
probability 1 if p is 1/2, but
you won't have any steady state
probability, which is a
strange case, which we'll
talk about as we go on.
You looked at the truncated case
of this in the homework,
namely you looked at a case of
what happened if you just
truncated this chain of some
value n and you found the
steady state probabilities.
And what you found was that if
p is equal to 1/2, the steady
state probabilities
are uniform.
If p is greater than 1/2, the
states over in this end have
high probabilities, they travel
down geometrically to
the states at this end.
If p is less than 1/2, the
states are highly probable and
these state go down
geometrically
as you go out here.
What do you think happens if you
take this truncated chain
and then start moving n further
and further out?
Well, if you have the nice case
where the probabilities
are mostly clustered around 0,
then as you keep moving it out
it doesn't make any
difference.
In fact, you look at the answer
you've got and see what
happens in the limit as you
take into infinity.
But, if you look at the case
where p is greater than 1/2,
then everything is clustered
up at the right n and every
time you increase the number
of states by 1, blah.
Everything goes to hell.
Everything goes to hell unless
you realize that you just move
everything up by 1, and then
you have the same case that
you had before.
So, you just keep moving
things up.
But there isn't any steady
state, and as advertised
things go to infinity.
If you look at the case where
p is equal to 1/2, as you
increase the number of states
what happens is all the states
get less and less likely.
You keep wandering around in
an aimless fashion, and
nothing very interesting
happens.
What we want to do, just to be
able to define recurrence, to
mean that given that you start
off in some state i, there's a
future return to state
i with probability 1.
That's what recurrence should
mean, that's what recurrence
means in English.
Recurrence means
you come back.
Since it's probabilistic, you
have to say, well we don't
know when we're going to get
back, but we are going to get
back eventually.
It's what you say to a friend
you don't want to see.
I'll see you sometime.
And then it might be an infinite
expected time.
But at least you said you're
going to make it back.
We will see the birth-death
chain above is recurrent in
this sense if p is less than
1/2, and it's not recurrent of
p is greater than 1/2, and we're
clearly going to have to
struggle a little bit to find
out what it is that
p is equal to 1/2.
And that's a strange case and
we'll call non-recurrent when
we get to that point.
We're going to use renewal
theory to study these
recurrent chains, which is why
we did renewal theory first.
But first we have to understand
first passage times
a little better.
We looked at first passage times
a little bit when we
were dealing with
Markov chains.
We looked at first passage
time by looking at the
expected first passage time to
get from one state to another
state, and we found a nice
clean way of doing that.
We'll see how that relates to
this, but here instead of
looking at the expected value
we want to find the
probability that you have a
return after some particular
period of time.
AUDIENCE: So why did
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: If p is greater
than 1/2, what's going to
happen is you keep wandering
further and
further off to the right.
You can come back.
There's a certain probability
that no matter how far you get
out there, there's
a probability
that you can get back.
But there's also a probability
that you won't get back, that
you keep getting bigger
and bigger.
And this is not obvious.
But it's something that we're
going to sort out as we go on.
But it certainly is plausible
that there's a probability, a
positive probability that
you'll never return.
Because the further you go, the
harder it is to get back.
And the drift is always
to the right.
And since the drift is always to
the right, the further you
get away, the less probable it
gets that you ever get back.
And we will analyze this.
I mean, for this case, it's
not very hard to analyze.
Where were we?
OK.
The first pass each time
probability, we're going to
call it f sub ij of n.
This is the probability
given that you're in
state i at time zero.
It's the probability that you
reach state j for the first
time a time n.
It's not the probability that
you're in state j at time n,
which is what we call
p sub i j to the n.
It's just the probability
that you get there
for the first time.
At time n.
If you remember, quick comment
about notation.
We called p sub ij is the
probability that xj, xn equals
j, given that x0 equals i.
And f sub ij.
And now the n is in parentheses
as the probability
that xn is equal to j, given
that x0 equals i, and x1 x2,
so forth are unequal to j.
Now you see why I get confused
with i's and j's.
The reason I'm using parentheses
here and using a
subscript here is when we're
dealing with finite state
Markov chains, it was just so
convenient to view this as the
ij component of the matrix p
taken to the n-th power.
And this is to remind you that
this is a matrix taken to the
n-th power.
And the you take
the ij element.
There isn't any matrix
multiplication here.
This is partly because we're
dealing with countable state
and Markov chains here.
But partly also because this is
an uglier thing that we're
dealing with.
But you can still
work this out.
What's the probability that you
will be in state j for the
first time at n, given
you're back in i?
It's really the probability
that the sum of the
probability that on the
first transition, you
move from i to k.
Some k unequal to j, because
if we're equal to j, we'd
already be there, and we
wouldn't be looking at
anything after that.
So it's the probability
we move from i to k.
And then we have n minus 1
transitions to get from k back
to j for the first time.
If you think you understand
this, most things like this,
you can write them either way.
You can look at the first
transition followed by n minus
1 transitions after it, or you
can look at the n minus 1
transitions first, followed
by the last transition.
Here you can't do that.
And you should look at it,
and figure out why.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
I just was wondering if it's
the same to say that all of
the [INAUDIBLE] are given, like
you would in [INAUDIBLE]?
And [INAUDIBLE]
all of them given just
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's the probability
that all of the
x1, x2, x3 and so forth
are not equal to j.
AUDIENCE: Because here and
there, you did [INAUDIBLE]
exactly the same question.
In here, [INAUDIBLE]
given [INAUDIBLE].
And they're [INAUDIBLE]
the same?
PROFESSOR: This is the
same as that, yes.
Except it's not totally obvious
why it is, and I'm
trying to explain why it is.
I mean, you look at the first
transition you take.
You start out in state i.
The next place you go, if it's
state j, you're all through.
And then you've gotten to
state j in one step, and
that's the end of it.
But if you don't get to state j
in one step, you get to some
other state k.
And then the question you ask
is what's the probability
starting from state k that you
will reach j for the first
time in n minus 1 steps?
If you try to match up
these two equations,
it's not at all obvious.
If you look at what this first
transition probability means,
then it's easy to get
this from that.
And it's easy to get
But anyway, that's what it is.
f sub ij of 1 is equal to pij,
and therefore this is equal to
n greater than one.
And you can use this recursion,
and you can go
through and calculate all
of these n-th order
probabilities, as some
[INAUDIBLE] is going to point
out in just a minute.
It takes a while to
do that for an
infinite number of states.
But we assume there's some nice
formula for doing it.
I mean, this is a formula
you could in
principal, compute it.
OK, so here's the same
formula again.
I want to relate that to the
probabilities of being in
state j at time n, given the you
were in state i at time 0.
Which by Chapman and
Kolmogorov is
this equation here.
That's the same.
You go first to state
k, and then from
kj, n minus one steps.
Here you're summing over all k,
and you're summing over all
k because in fact, if you get to
state j in the first step,
you can still get to state
j again after n
minus one more steps.
Here you're only interested
in the first time you
get to state j.
Here you're interested in any
time you get to state j.
I bring this up because remember
what you did when you
solve that problem related to
rewards with a Markov chain?
If you can think back to that.
The way to solve the reward
problem, trying to find the
first pass each time from sum
i to sum j was to just take
all the outputs from state
j and remove them.
If you look at this formula,
you'll see that that's exactly
what we've done mathematically
by summing only over
k unequal to j.
Every time we get to j, we
terminate the whole thing, and
we don't proceed any further.
So this is just a mathematical
way of saying just a Markov
chain by ripping all of the
outputs out of state j, and
putting a self loop
in state j.
OK, so this is really saying
the same sort of thing that
that was saying, except that
was only giving us expected
value, and this is giving
us the whole thing.
Now, the next thing is we would
like to find what looks
like a distribution function
for the same thing.
This is the probability
of reaching j
by time n or before.
And the probability that you
reach state j by time n or
before it's just the sum of
the probabilities that you
reach state j for the first time
at some time m less than
or equal to n.
It's a probability of reaching
j by time n or before.
If this limit now is equal
to 1, it means that with
probability 1, you eventually
get there.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry,
Professor Gallager.
I'm [INAUDIBLE] definition
of fij of n.
So is it the thing you wrote
on the board, or is it the
thing in the notes?
Like, I don't see why
they're the same.
Because the thing in the notes,
you're only given that
x0 is equal to i.
But the thing on the board,
you're given that x0 is equal
to i, and you're given that
x1, x2, none of them
are equal to j.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
This is--
you are absolutely right.
And then given x0 equals i.
Does that make sense now?
I can't see in my mind if
that's equal to this.
But if I sit there quietly and
look at it for five minutes, I
realize why this is
equal to that.
And that's why I write it down
wrong half the time.
So, if this limit is equal to
1, it means I can define a
random variable, which is the
amount of time that it takes
to get to state j for
the first time.
And that random variable is a
non defective random variable,
because I always get to
state j eventually,
starting from state i.
Now, what was awkward about this
was the fact that I had
to go through all these
probabilities before I could
say let t sub ij be a random
variable, and let that random
variable be the number of steps
that it takes to get to
state j, starting in state i.
And I couldn't do that because
it wasn't clear there was a
random variable.
If I said it was as effective
random variable, then it would
be clear that there had
to be some sort of
defective random variable.
But then I'd have to deal with
the question of what do I
really mean by defective
random variable?
Incidentally, the notes does
not define what a defective
random variable is.
If you have a non-negative thing
that might be a random
variable, the definition of a
defective random variable is
that all these probabilities
exist, but the limit is not
equal to 1.
In other words, sometimes
the thing never happens.
So that you can either look at
this as you have a thing like
a random variable, but it
matched a lot of sample points
into infinity.
Or you can view it as
it maps a lot of
sample points into nothing.
But you still have a
distribution function for it.
OK.
But anyway, now we can talk
about a random variable, which
is the time to get from state i
to state j, if in fact, it's
certain that we're going
to get there.
Now, if you start out with
a definition of this
distribution function here, and
you play with this formula
here, you play with that
formula, and that formula a
little bit, you can rewrite
the formula for this
distribution function like thing
in the following way.
This is only different from the
thing we wrote before by
the presence of pij here.
Otherwise, little fij of n is
equal to just a sum over here
without that.
With this, you keep adding up,
and it keeps getting bigger.
Why I want to talk about this,
it's sort of a detail.
But this equation is always
satisfied by these
distribution function
like things.
But these equations do not
necessarily solve for these
quantities.
How do I see that?
Well, if I plug one in for x sub
ij of n, and f sub ij of n
minus 1 for all i and all
j, what do I get?
I get one that's equal to p
sub ij plus the sum over k
unequal to j of p
sub ik times 1.
So I get 1 equals 1.
So a solution to this equation
is that all of the fij's are
equal to 1.
Is this disturbing?
Well, no, it shouldn't be,
because all the time we can
write equations for things, and
the equations don't have a
unique solution.
And these equations don't
have a unique solution.
We never said they did.
But there is a theorem in the
notes, which says that if you
look at all the solutions to
this equation, and you take
the smallest solution, that
the smallest solution
is the right one.
In other words, the smallest
solution is the solution you
get from doing it
this other way.
I mean, this solution always
works, because you can always
solve for these quantities.
And you don't have to--
I mean, you're just using
iteration, so all these
quantities exist.
OK.
Now finally, these equations
for going from state i to
state j also work for going
from state j to state j.
If the probability of going
from state j to state j
eventually is equal to 1, that's
what we said recurrent
ought to mean.
And now we have a precise
way of saying it.
If f sub jj to infinity is equal
to 1, an eventual return
from state j occurs with
probability 1, and the
sequence of returns is a
sequence of renewal epochs in
a renewal process.
Nice, huh?
I mean, when we looked at finite
state in Markov chains,
we just sort of said this
and we're done with it.
Because with finite state
and Markov chains,
what else can happen?
You start in a particular
state.
If it's a recurrent state, you
keep hitting that state, and
you keep coming back.
And then you hit it again.
And the amount of time from
one hit to the next hit is
independent, as the next hit
to the next yet hit.
It was clear that you had
a renewal process there.
Here it's still clear that you
have a renewal process, if you
can define this random
variable.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you say the
smallest set you mean sum
across all terms of the
set, and whichever
gives you the smallest.
PROFESSOR: No, I mean
each of the values
being as small as possible.
I mean, it turns out that the
solutions are monotonic in
that sense.
You can find some solutions
where these are big and these
are small, and others where
these are little,
and these are big.
OK.
So now we know what this
distribution function is.
We know what a recurrent
state is.
And what do we do with it?
Well, we say there's a random
variable with this
distribution function.
We keep doing things
like this.
We keep getting more
and more abstract.
I mean, instead of saying here's
a random variable and
here's what its distribution
function is, we say if this
was a random variable, then
state j is recurrent.
It has this distribution
function.
The renewal process of returns
to j, then, has inter renewal
intervals with this distribution
function.
As soon as we have this renewal
process, we can state
this lemma, which are things
that we proved when we were
talking about renewal theory.
And let me try to explain why
each of them is true.
Let's start out by assuming
that state j is recurrent.
In other words, you have this
random variable, which is the
amount of time it takes
to get back to j.
If you get back to j with
probability one, then ask the
question, how long does it take
to get back to j for the
second time?
Well, you have a random
variable, which is the time
that it takes to get from j
to j for the first time.
You add this to a random
variable, which is the amount
of time to get from j to
j the second time.
You add two random variables
together, and you
get a random variable.
In other words, the second
return is sure if
the first one is.
The second return occurs with
probability 1 if the first
return occurs with
probability--
I mean, you have a very long
wait for the first return.
But after that very long
wait, you just have a
very long wait again.
But it's going to happen
eventually.
And the third return happens
eventually, and the fourth
return happens eventually.
So this says that as t goes
to infinity, the number of
returns up to time t is
going to be infinite.
Very small rate, perhaps.
If I look at the expected value
of the number of returns
up until time t, that's going to
be equal to infinity, also.
I can't think of any easy
way of arguing that.
If I look at the sum over all n
of the probability that I'm
in this state j at time n,
and I add up all those
probabilities, what do I get?
When I add up all those
probabilities, I'm adding up
the expectations of having
a renewal at time n.
By adding that up for all n.
And this, in fact, is exactly
the same thing as this.
So if you believe that, you
have to believe this also.
And then we just go back and
repeat the thing if these
things are not random
variables.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
what you mean [INAUDIBLE]?
I thought that we
put [INAUDIBLE]
2 and 3?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: And given
3, we proof 4.
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And we don't have time
to prove that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
But in fact, it's not hard to
say suppose one doesn't occur,
then, should the other
stuff occur.
But none of these imply that the
expected value of t sub jj
is finite, or infinite.
You can always have random
variables, which are random
variables, namely this is an
integer value random variable.
It always takes on some
integer value.
But the expected value of that
value might be infinite.
I mean, you've seen all sorts of
random variables like that.
You have a random variable where
the probability of j is
some constant divided
by j squared.
Now, you multiply j by 1 over 2
squared, you sum it over j,
and you've got infinity.
OK, so you might have these
random variables, which have
an expected return time,
which is infinite.
That's exactly what happens when
you look at these back
right at the beginning
of today.
1, 2, 4.
I'm going to look at this kind
of chain here, and I set p
equal to one half.
What we said was that you just
disperse here the probability
that you're going to be in any
state after a long time goes
to zero, but you have to
get back eventually.
And if you look at that
condition carefully, and you
put it together with all the
things we found out about
Markov chains, you realize that
the expected time to get
back has to be infinite
for this case.
And the same for the next
example we looked at.
If you look at p equals 1/2, you
don't have a steady state
probability.
Because you don't have a steady
state probability, the
expected time to get back, the
expected recurrence time has
an infinite expected value.
The expected recurrence time
has to be 1 over the
probability of the state.
So the probability of
the state is 0.
The expected return time
has to be infinite.
So, where were we?
Well, two states are in
the same class if they
communicate.
Same as for finite
state chains.
That's the same argument we
gave, and you get from there
to there, and there to there.
And you get from here to there,
and here to here, then
you get from here to there,
and here to there.
OK.
If states i and j are in the
same class, then either both
are recurrent, or both
are transient.
Which means not recurrent.
If j is recurrent, then we've
already found that this sum is
equal to infinity.
And then, oh, I have to explain
this a little bit.
What I'm trying to show you is
that if j is recurrent, then i
has to be recurrent.
And I know that j is
recurrent if this
sum is equal to infinity.
And if this sum is equal to
infinity, let's look at how we
can get from i back
to i in n steps.
Since i and j communicate,
there's some path of some
number of steps, say m, which
guesses from i to j.
There's also some path of say,
length l which gets us
from j back to k.
And if there's this path, and
there's this path, and then I
sum this over all k, that I get
is a lower bound to that.
I first go to j, and then I
spend an infinite number of
states constantly coming
back to j.
And then I finally
go back to i.
And what that says is that this
sum of p sub i, i to the
n, I mean, this is just one
set of paths which gets us
from i to i in n steps.
If state j is recurrent, then
t sub jj might or might not
have a finite expectation.
All I want to say here is that
if t sub jj, the time to get
from state j back to state j has
an infinite expectation,
then you call state j.
No recurrent instead of
regular recurrent.
As we were just saying, if that
expected recurrence time
is infinite, then the steady
state probability is going to
be zero, which says that if
something is no recurrent,
it's going to be even a very,
very different way from when
it's positive recurrent, which
is when the return time has a
finite value.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Which means there isn't a steady
state probability.
To have a steady state
probability, you want them all
to add up to 1.
So yes, they're all zero.
And formally, there isn't a
steady state probability.
OK, thank you.
We will--